gosh damn it where's my video I have no
video for today right where's the video
hello you had one job Brad oopsie I did
an oopsie okay guess it's time to make
one now you owe me and then I lit it by
[Laughter]
having a great idea let's review that
you had one job sub ready that's a great
idea let's reel him out of nowhere now I
don't make youtube videos anymore I
don't want to do really weird that you
can the fact that this isn't working is
what makes it work so yeah for sure
we're looking at the one job subreddit
so you will learn that you have one job
which is to edit videos yes sorry sir
chocolate now zero $89
Wow what a great price a spun of oh my
favorite
you ever had a spa no Brad Oh No
this hurts me well school remains shoes
in Swedish do you think that's what it
is score want some score 39 grams of
shoes you sell shoes and grams in Sweden
that's how we know the sizes 20 White's
87 cents what why is it such yeah this
is fake I don't know what do you reckon
wait wait they wrote knickers and sicker
what how it can't be real
this can't be real someone picked up
that chocolate bar turned upside down
and went our way today it looks like
it's the it looks like a word the make a
fake sign no way dude real or fake I
vote I vote fake I was real because I
want to believe that people are stupid
who on earth accepted the
as a return this item is from the summer
of 2000 that was almost 17 years ago our
return policy is 45 days sure ask
management oh no I mean it looks pretty
clean though it looks like it hasn't
been worn yet yeah it looks pretty fresh
who realise out of nowhere hey I'm gonna
return that one shirt they must have put
that away and then gone oh I never wore
this because it's and they've outgrown
it or something you know but the thing
is it work they must have got their
money back
2450 back yeah we still got the tag on
it I've just realized look this this is
okay by me
I'd give a guy like what is that 20
bucks I'd give a guy 20 bucks who came
in and was like yeah yeah that was
pretty good I'd wear that swag swagg
real you wrote you reckon real I reckon
real - yeah the hell am I looking at
this is not a joke okay so there we go
that's how you know it's real yeah we
paid a photographer who claimed to be a
professional two hundred and fifty
dollars for a family photo shoot please
see these four real photos okay that's
definitely for real
I should deliver to it she said the
shadows were really bad on the beautiful
clear sunny day and that her professor
never taught her to retouch photos feel
free to share I literally have not
laughed at this hard for years she says
oh my god it looks like a game that you
play what's that game called
well you have to go to their house and
they have an argument in the kitchen all
right no concern no that's it no you've
gotta know I don't know I don't know I
don't know facade facade facade oh how
did this size of their eyes change if
she's retouching the photo could you
hand that over to someone seriously
I mean you look you look further away
and it's like you know it's the guy
doesn't look too bad on the right
actively relatively speaking to the
other the lighting also it can't be that
bad
surely cuz look at the dogs yeah I was
thinking the same yeah I don't know like
I she she said my professor never taught
me to retouch photos well you don't say
I told the truth in a twitch stream the
other day right and it was I'm just
curious as to whether you're still sort
of eating the powder of the G fuel what
do you mean you told me that you like
the cotton candy flavor so much that
you've been spooning it up in your hand
and eating it without diluting it with
war and I know you're still doing it
because I'm gonna die I love you I love
to you more than you love money and
that's a lot a bomb yeah but if that
without diluting it you are going to die
and you don't brand so stop trying to
trick me let me eat directly the [ __ ]
Andy and slowly kill my to promote
eating it just like I'm not promoting it
I just told you I like it
what he's got to make sure you don't
breathe it in when you put it in your
mouth that's all you get ya know that's
what it is it's just breathing in you
could eat as much of it as you want in
powder form but don't breathe it in
that's what get ya Clifford the Big Red
Dog he knows a lot about divorce dating
and sex after forty five and he won't
spare you the gory details
oh my word Netflix what is this
Netflix dark reboot of Clifford the Big
Red Dog live further that picture looks
sexually intended as well like it looks
like something's going on yeah it looks
like something's going on at the other
end of the picture the sand
buried him in the sand but but one part
of Clifford is still showing his big
race okay Paul this one has to be real
yeah they is up all the time don't they
yeah they do
postman Gibbs zero Epps 100 percent Mia
I don't this happened to me already
oh my god for sure yeah yeah this is
this happens every day no down
whatsoever the beginning of Ace Ventura
where he smash in the Box up oh yeah on
the street his knife it's not him like
making a play on postman this is just
how they are I think it's what they have
to do I think it's just playin ya
understand as well if it was my job I
would also do the same thing yeah
whenever there is signs on the things
that says like okay please be careful or
this side up I'm always thinking like
why bother then it's like when you have
luggage and you're like this is fragile
and then you look out ya know the plane
and they're launching them into the got
new doors at work Paul push but that's
the sign they must have bought that I
guess so yeah right okay nice a strange
polling technique maybe this is the
introduced to the Jedi Temple
Oh force pushing porch vocals pole yeah
it still kind of doesn't make sense but
it's the best it could it could be photo
shot but I don't think so just based on
the shadowing for sure real real so many
people are at fault the guy that made it
the guy that bought it and the employee
that put it up the guy that sold that as
well or their women well I've seen this
one before and I already think it's fake
don't be silly
wrap your willy take one for free yeah
this is for sure just in someone's like
University dorm room you know like no
meme yeah they were like haha this is
funny who writes a smiley face the wrong
sign I hope some drunk freshman there's
an egg stupidly and you
that's the issue here really is that one
a person will use one of them you know
so the person who'd made this is like
haha this is a funny joke but there is a
dumbass out there who will pick one of
those off the wall then use it I think
what's more likely is that someone picks
it off the wall and gave it to someone
because you want to really see that it's
poking home lepak prank
[Music]
now just put an effing comma people are
eating children in this area please
leash your dog and clean up after them
thank you what what am i you know people
are eating color children oh my god
people are eating it's just like like
this is inclusivity gone crazy where we
start to accept cannibals back into
society you know this is a cannibal
society this is a cannibal eating
children area please if you don't mind
this is where cannibals eat their
children walk their dogs okay and you're
discriminating against cannibals if you
don't let them I do not want any
engraving just leave the metal plate
blank plate sir I do not want any
blank no engraving and then that arrives
Oh God and certainly so absolutely good
God
you know this is an America I mean not
just from the look of them oh my god I
didn't even see you funny little screen
I'm looking at oh my god what are you
plugging in your sink music school zone
[Laughter]
wait what is it supposed to say school
free drug drug free school zone surely
but the person who put it out it was
just on some drugs their name they've
put it up all look at it it's screwed oh
wow I like these because I don't know
what the issue is right away
dinosaur kids pillow case I don't see
the issue the issue is that you think
you're buying the pillowcase but if you
look it's just the image of the kid on
the would you like this picture of a
child sleeping to sleep on this no way
surely this is a joke like someone has
downloaded the JPEG and printed it on
that like ironed it onto their own
pillowcase dinosaur kids pillowcase I
got a fine it yeah it's fake yeah they
change the photo
just imagine Keith getting stuck at the
bottom slide closed yeah that's the
wrong yeah it's the wrong end there's
been four children in there for 30 years
they're adults they're just the tunnel
people was there and growing up they
were managed to come out from the lane
they have to grow tall enough to reach
them giving them food down there they've
been living in there for years Santa
I've been a good girl please stop she
says Christ moving on next the image
thank you that's not even Santa he just
lied to a creep
creeped up behind her life it's me Santa
oh wow great soccer players seriously
what is wrong with them they ruin this
sport because everyone just thinks
they're from bunch of [ __ ] cuz
they're all like super ripped they're
all like strong and really athletic if
you if you had a fight with one in the
street they would kick they would kick
the hell out of you you can pretend to
be injured but if you if you're injured
as an adult male now you just go ah oh
bloody on my leg oh you don't you don't
like put your hand up to your head like
I must cover my face now from the
immense pain so no one can see it my leg
you don't do that you go ah you've
kicked me in machines no kids the dogs
run away The Washington Post the perfect
Aryan child that's the end of the video
that's the end of the video everyone Wow
we're completely out of time right there
what a shame if only what I showed just
wanted to see what it was about him
due to time deal so next time due to tie
that's it I guess we'll have to see in
the next one in the next video if we get
enough thumbs up and smash likes
videos smashed like and don't eat G fuel
dry remember to use cold PT pipe at the
checkout that's delicious
you want pyramids we got oh oh you're
into castles huh we got you covered baby
you want some bets easy we got it all
this game is still relevant goddammit
[Music]